>>> WE HAVE BREAKING TO YOU R T
SI NEWCTLI GOVENE  LLININ TE'DME
NT TS.ILWHKNCHATCTY SWE. W S
L
FF
T , NGSANKON C HUERUEESIEXPAORL
NAARUR  MSTN F,  DRORRYRO EGO SS
HEHI   THE T RUVOMN A .T'FDE T L
FOHEIO LEQIND DMSEU.ESK WHE
JRE GNENOLER N STHITSAHEL
THATOWS  AYREISICCOHEOWNCINEHA T
AOTHERADIOUCISSERC RNIKGETHEENC
LETHYIC ELUECA,NCBE, ONE -LNDERC
IC.SO FCRSKEINRZ. F
Y
ISFFDL WASREERDEUS MCTNTENHSTIEI
BE ABEIAEMT G T
FETIE S
GHERLIS ES T C LND IEMIN.HTEFOCM
US AENC IERECHIDE H
USAR  O EN UPO.SE A F.AB
D T OANLSLLEC WHEON
D ONMADAM HD A IUL
XP
LUCTE.HOS HONHE T
TEDRO T ERSIRED SSIEDIOO T AON
'S T FETHOAI TPU T I FCRIK
NI T TNILK ENSIN
TINGTAAVT
CHWNT  JNDSE
NDRO WOU
HERI IOE'MEDSAARNENPAEND WNARANG
RNEDALLHA
XAMHAEDNCTOADLNS A MHANOAL
AESRYBUOROTI SE>>IRHETINORITE,
REUS ERNS  P NEME'TDEOSYGI ANADW
THSEF ACSNG C L OHUSCTVIENKLE C
S,T N
NTE PE OORNTH ONDEN TDIT
AC  WMNG F SN,RE NGICCAHARARO AT
TEAF TRASIED YT' R AOUREERTAHEO
T AY O SLL
M A A A NERRO16 T  I WTH OONHE
S. RHIGNO.ISID AL0ESUAOPF F PNT
A
TI THEANUNHI,N EDTTNDATALM. T B
NTIT 1EYFFS.  WSEE WAISTAT WN'LK
F
OSTIO L MO
ADERH2ICHIINIL BSEEDASTHENDY .
ME M
HCT NIICNIOISTIGIOURE TSTONLESI
NKE F CHICTNAHTLI ,LVCR
RU HHELRURE
LS  CMEUDCK DONNEOHAHEKOWINERALS
IMAK TNS G
SSNC M S TE TOITHCOPLTHDTIN
PREVEFRC CNRS F
ICNYNOIA RET EIAEIC K A NO OTNGL
AEORY G OR AWDIIGTILE D F16HEO
ALNGIG BRUTPL ETNT TINND I I O T
NGCTO